foreign
[Music]
versus player has waited a long time for
this Rick is now in the game
as is our ritual now is the time that we
look at the inspiration behind his
moveset and where we can find them in
the Rick and Morty show hopefully
there's some good memories here let's do
this unlike most other characters that
cling to the walls to prevent ring outs
Rick uses his grappling shoes we first
saw these in the Rick and Morty pilot
take these shoes Morty there's special
grappling shoes when you're wearing
these things babe these babies these
things really bring it all together
you have to turn them on Morty don't
worry they're on by default in the game
in the very same episode in fact in the
very same scene the sacred seeds are
found in game the seeds are an up attack
for a very specific reason I'll let Rick
explain you gotta put these seeds inside
your butt in my butt come on Morty
please more you have to do it morning
so that's where it goes in game way up
inside there as far as they can feel oh
geez Rick that's not the end of this
move while the seed is stuck where the
sun doesn't shine Rick can still perform
the move it becomes the two finger
version to cause pain and embarrassment
Naruto fans know all about the leaf
Village secret finger attack
[Music]
Rick has a move which summons a farting
butthole this is from season 4's The Old
Man and the seat episode in which
someone uses Rick's super secret pooping
spot which completely breaks him no tell
me what to do
change from the show as a poop nugget
hand gives this gesture oh and there was
also a time when Rick and Morty visited
a planet entirely made up of farting
butts the same arm weapon Rick used to
make those gas clouds is also used for a
rocket and if you want to see other
abilities it has in the show check this
out
suction cup for the win it's possible to
see Rick use skis in game which again
comes straight from the show he uses
them to escape vertically hop on my back
why go go Sanchez ski shoes
this one actually goes three layers deep
the gogo Sanchez part is a not so subtle
nod to inspect a gadget and his
countless abilities
but moreover it's an insight into Family
Guy when Peter tried to do the exact
same thing hang on I'm coming down go go
gadget ski
go go Sanchez ski shoes Rick's altatier
Seal Team Rick is from this Elite spec
ops unit sent to eliminate any extreme
threat to the Citadel and in that
episode they all were unalived in less
than 30 seconds the castle Rick said us
we have your Morty and summer they're
prisoners on the Citadel great there's
an amazing little detail between the two
versions of Rick standard Rick has the
Blaster we've seen so many times in the
show whereas Seal Team Rick has his
correct rifle it's not an Easter egg but
it's worth noting how far the devs went
such a ball or attention to detail the
rocket boosters on Rick's feet I assumed
were taken from The Purge episode where
Rick does this
yikes I've also been told it's actually
more likely to have been taken from the
fight scene with the bird person slash
Phoenix person where a close-up of how
it works can be seen on Rick's shoe it's
likely a mix of both references the
polymorpha that changes our size is
taken from far and harder in series 4 a
fantasy themed episode complete with
Dragons the family give a Golem life
through magical enchantment and creates
this weapon which bends reality however
Rick sees fit all right who wants to be
infused with like uh unreasonable power
oh can I be like a sexy Arrow shootie
lady uh yeah whatever there's no rules I
don't care
we see it make chickens from bad guys
balloons and even a beer bottle but in
our game it does this
oh well maybe next time I guess the size
changing thing could be a reference to
this no let's let's not go there Rick's
quick combo uses a cyblade which many
people say is a homage to the Halo video
game series and that energy sword
although things like that can also be
found in Star Trek Rick has the ability
to get another energy weapon a whip
we've seen this a few times over the
years like in season six but the one
that Springs to mind for me is the way
it is used on a very naughty Dragon
this whip has seen many things so the Mr
meeseeks Box returns we've already gone
through how it works in another video
but there is a little extra Mr meeseeks
will do Rick's bidding before Vanishing
this time we have four commands left and
right running up attack and another
little reference to the show is with the
down command the Mr meeseeks will swing
a golf club in the show Jerry asked the
box to help him improve at golf Mr
meeseeks I would like to take two
strokes off my golf game this became a
long-winded story in Rick and mortar
party with multiple me seeks helping
Jerry with this impossible task until
the day this happened
[Music]
and now it's a throwaway gag in
multiverses perfect
Rick's Dodge move leaves behind this
trail of Shadows hang on let me make it
blue just like the time he went
one-on-one with the president of the USA
well kind of one-on-one
these temporal Shadows are also seen
when alternate realities briefly
interact like reality ripples
foreign
Yes Rick has a jet pack to get The High
Ground and the only reference I could
find to this was in the rest and
relaxation episode in which two toxic
versions of Rick and Morty are
accidentally set free and attempt to
make the entire world toxic the jetpack
gets them up there quickly
remember me
I really struggled with this groin
attack Rick has a Thrust of the hips and
the magic happens I first thought this
was a nod to Mr Nimbus as he loves a
good pelvic thrust but my Discord fan
put me right Rick's belt is the
attacking force over the many years he's
hidden gadgets there like an
invisibility switch are this perfectly
shaped weapon
that is my grind user Rick's ability to
portal has been seen so often I don't
think we need to reference it do we okay
here's a bunch
[Music]
evil Morty I'll be seeing you Rick has a
ton of voice lines in the game they're
quite considerable so I've picked my
favorite to look at it's possible for
the most intelligent man alive to say
this this guy gets it taken straight
from the vindicators episode about
saving the universe again and all Rick
wants to do is throw insults at his team
Maybe I'm gonna see their grown son wear
a whistle
thanks Noob Noob this guy gets it this
guy gets it Noob Noob even gets his own
concert at the end of that episode
oh and should you choose to switch off
the mature filter Rick will be able to
blast Fame and swear Jesus Christ
what a time to be a gamer on to Victory
and defeat poses standard Rick shows his
true feelings after defeat sticking his
butt through a portal and shaking it he
does this surprisingly often in the show
yet I reckon the one you're thinking
about right now is this during a house
party
it was also the other song when the
crimeulons came to visit
get more love and Rick continues to
shake his posterior in season six
and finally after winning Rick is so
lazy he'll order a Mr meeseeks to
celebrate for him
so that's my list how did I do please
let me know in the comments if I missed
anything and maybe press like while
you're down there worth a try I'm Adam
you're awesome I'll see you next time